lamsten Robin Rechtsanwalt in Österreich
und in den USA und in meiner
Milizfunktion bin ich Offizier beim
Jakob anders
als junger Mensch hat mich natürlich
auch das Abenteuer bei Militär und
insbesondere beim JA Kommando fasziniert
und angezogen aber es ist viel mehr als
ein Abenteuer ich bin bei der Miliz aus
Überzeugung aus Patriotismus und weil
ich mir sicher bin dass ich sehr viel
vom Militär gelernt habe und ich bin
stolz darauf
dieser ukraine-konflikt zeigt uns dass
es ein Bundesheer ein starkes
bundesheerbedarf und das die Stimmen die
davon ausgehen dass es keine Konflikte
mehr geben wird doch verstummen wir
wünschen sonst aber es ist nicht
realistisch in der Ukraine sieht man das
Menschen bereit sind für Vaterland zu
kämpfen oder für ihre Umgebung für Ihren
Ort für ihre Gemeinde für alles was
ihnen etwas wert ist
ich habe viel Zeit im Ausland verbracht
und viele Jahre in Amerika gelebt und
besonders wenn man von außen wieder
zurück nach Österreich kommt weiß man
eigentlich was Österreich zu bieten hat
welche Qualitäten österreich hat man
kann bei uns das Wasser trinken wir
haben eine tolle Sozialversicherung wir
haben viele Errungenschaften und ich
glaube dass der Blick von außen vielen
helfen könnte sich auch Gedanken dazu zu
machen bin ich bereit dies zu
verteidigen